[inaudible].
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 31st, 2017 what's going on? How are you? What's going on?
Ah, Jesus Christ.
How she is I, is it going to be a heat
wave? The heats comment back. Oh my God,
please try to stay in sigh inside the air conditioning.
If you don't have air conditioning,
please try to remember to keep your windows open and stick your head through the
opening in the window, not in the solid part of the wall.
You know when they do that shit on the news and they try to help old people not
die in the summer heat?
What a fucking way to go. You'll live almost a century and just, you know,
you've lived through the wars, you've lived through the depression,
you've lived through the fucking New York in the 70s and all that.
What finally gets you a hot summer day and you're just sitting there,
right?
So swirling four and you just can't, you just can't get to the window.
It's like when you'd watch wrestling, right?
And it's one of those tag team wrestling matches and the guy just can't get to
his teammate to fucking slap his hand at tagament.
That's what it is. That's it. They lie there.
They find them face down in wrestling trunks.
The greatest generation stormed the beaches of Normandy taken out by a fucking
heat wave. Does it every year. How many heroes?
How many years people are we going to put up with the sun?
Taken another one of our heroes away. I swear to God. You know,
maybe if there was a different administration,
they would handle the threat of the sun, right?
My talking politics now, is that what I'm doing? Let's talk politics.
Why? Why do we keep fucking with this Douche in Korea?
Why don't you just leave him alone? You know what I mean?
It's like when you're on the subway and the crazy guy comes in the car,
you don't look at him. You don't start talking to them.
Just fucking leave them alone. Leave them alone. Isn't nothing too.
Why don't they just let the fucking guy, you know,
run his country the way he wants to run his fucking country.
Send some food in there, feed the fucking people.
Why does he have to have the same fucking ideas about strip malls that we do in
order as for us to get along with them? Huh?
Haven't we proven that? It doesn't matter what kind of government you have.
In the end,
there's going to be human beings running it so they're going to selfishly fuck
the whole thing up anyways. Who gives a shit? If he's over there,
lighten off his fucking mat is, let them do it.
The guy is clearly unbelievably insecure.
He clearly is trying to follow in the footsteps of his dad's giant fucking
shoes. Although he's probably smaller.
I don't know how tall those guys are over there,
but whatever tall for over there. Big Shoes for North Korea,
especially with all the lack of nutrition that's got to stunt.
The growth of your feet is there. Right? Why don't they just fuck it. You know,
we should like when he shoots something off, we should just feed his ego. Wow.
There you go. We'll go there. Kim Jong eldest second.
Whenever you fucking name is. Hey, you very case.
I was a good one too. That sec. You like that? Look it. Look at ours.
It's awesome. Fist bump. Good man. Good man. Hey,
here's a copy of the last year. Super Bowl. Check it out man.
It's fucking amazing. What do you got? You got a Mug, Gangnam style DVD.
You want to trade with us? Why can't we just try to get along with this guy?
What is the fucking problem? Oh,
like we give a shit. What the fuck he's doing to his people? These kinds.
Who Runs Shit over here?
They don't give a fuck how many people are upside down in their own house.
They didn't give a fuck about the people in New Orleans.
They give a fuck about those people in North Korea. No, they do not. No,
they do not.
You know what it is that they're sitting on a bunch of material that you could
turn into those doctors, those beats by Dre. God Damn it.
We want it so that's where we're going to do.
We're going to act like this fucking Goddamn fat show with his fucking three
missiles is going to be a problem.
Um,
yeah. I don't want to just leave the guy alone. They're talking now, right?
According to Google news that I didn't even read it.
All I did was just click on it says US allies prepared to use overwhelming force
in North Korea. General says, uh,
we're prepared to shoot a bunch of missiles in his general area,
says the general hoping that one of them lands on him and we kill his few
innocent people as possible.
They would never say that the US and its allies are prepared to use rapid and
lethal,
rapid lethal and overwhelming force if necessary against North Korea.
The commander of the U S Pacific Air Forces warn Saturday night.
And why are we doing this?
Cause this guy's shooting off his own fireworks cause he's testing missiles the
way we do a North Korea remains the most urgent threat to regional stability.
O Shaughnessy said, Oh Shaughnessy you've done it again.
Yeah, Jesus Christ.
Do we really got to go in there and blow this guy up with a bunch of other
people just trying to fucking get to work. It's gotta be another way to do it.
Don't, don't, don't we have any James Bonds,
guys that can just kind of go in there and start banging the hottest chits
chicks in North Korea as they subtly try to kill them, you know?
But the power of his dick is so overwhelming. They forget to kill him.
And then he realized then by the time they realized I was supposed to kill that
guy, but I was so busy having orgasms, right. He's already out the door.
He's got the past codes, and then he goes down there.
How would you kill that guy? How would you kill that fat bastard? You know?
You know what I would do? I'd give him a honey of a ham. You know,
the glazed ones that they have around Christmas except in the glaze would be
some sort of Sinai. That's where you hide the poison, you know?
And he would just be staring at it and a witch's mouth would be watering so much
that he couldn't wait for the official taste tester to give it a try, you know?
And he would literally die while making himself a sandwich. You know,
when you're so hungry,
you making the sandwich and you're already fucking thrown chunks and meat in
your mouth. That's when he would be doing, so it'd be two price.
What does he look like? He looks like a white bread guy, doesn't he?
He's definitely not a multigrain, you know?
Do you think he gets an everything Bagel on the way to work every day?
Okay.
Had a hairless bastard. I bet he doesn't even have to wear deodorant. You know,
there's a lot of things to like about him. He's fat, you know?
So he's nonthreatening. Yeah.
That means he likes teaks likes to fucking stay up late and Netflix and chill.
You can see that about him. You know, you think he knows how to dance.
I'd be noticed that about little people and, uh, in fat, in fat people,
they transcend race when it comes to dancing, you know?
It's like white guys can't dance pretty much general,
unless they're fat or they're a little person.
Then all of a sudden they're just fucking, it's just like, wow,
will you in the beat it video, what's going on here? It's because they had to,
that's what happens.
You have to visit a certain amount of ice cream that you eat where the laws of
nature just take over and at some point you have to learn how to dance or you're
just going to be heading into an abyss of sadness that, you know,
there's not enough chips Ahoy in the world can fill that void.
Or is it that they get that sweat into the oldies Richard Simmons thing and that
just kind of launches this talent. They didn't know this is just for fat people.
I don't know about little people. You know, I think little people,
cause they're down at the ground, they can see the steps easier. You know,
where like when Michael Jackson first moonwalked, you know,
everybody was as tall as Michael Jackson,
so we couldn't figure out what he was doing with his feet.
But little people down at the ground, they, oh, I got that shit right.
And the next day you're in the subway. Don't, don't, don't, don't, don't. Oh,
bone, bone. And it was like fucking eight little people all coming at you.
Yeah. And you, Nia, did you ever see that
you ever go into the subways of Brooklyn and there was a bunch of little people
doing recreating the bad video? No.
That Jack [inaudible] bad. I'm bad.
No, no. What's going on? I'm going to stupid mode. I'm trying to say.
How would you North Korea?
Well, I don't have no idea.
You know, it's funny. He's like a baby, like baby fat.
That's what I like about that guy. Like if you wore shorts,
it probably looked like, oh cutie pies. There you get ready for it.
She just woke up. Oh you did? You did.
You want to go to Brooklyn today and watch us eat real people food while you
keep drinking milk?
Um, all right.
No, I dunno. I Dunno what I was talking,
I was talking about some fucking stupid shit. Yeah. So why,
why? Like honestly,
what would happen if we just left that guy alone?
You know what would happen if you just seriously asking this?
If you lifted all the sanctions and he was able to trade with the world and they
were able to fucking get some food in there, whatever the fuck's going on.
If you just honestly just let him do his shit.
I mean we shoot a fucking missiles all the time. We don't use la.
Wow.
This is what kills me. How do we even know what the fuck he's doing over there?
Who has fucking time to be watching this shit?
Can you imagine if that was your God damn job and then you'd go and home on the
subway and then you sit next to me and you're watching me losing my shit cause I
can't download the new operating system and you're sitting there dealing with
the fact
that there's some chubby little fella on the other side of the world shooting us
some shit that could possibly be on its way over here right now.
I don't know.
Do you think if the animals had the abilities,
they had the ability to shoot those missiles,
do you think they would do it in an effort to try to wipe all of us out so they
could just go back to fucking catch and trout in a stream?
You know, if there was going to be an animal out there that would betray us,
which, which species do you think it would be? You know,
it have to be something at least at the level of a bear reptiles or out reptiles
of like, you know, they're, they're like, you know,
there's those kids that go to the,
like reptiles have like learning disabilities, right?
They have like fucking dyslexia, uh,
add, you know,
they like the Ritalin kids of the animal kingdom or they even considered an
animal is a reptile, an animal. I always forget this shit. And Amphibian,
an amphibian is something that can be a,
it's like aqua man, right? And he's onto the ocean.
He's talking to a dolphin and then later on that night, you know,
he's getting Sushi. Oh, that'd be fucked up. Right?
It's on a Daikin Sushi dates sitting there looking at like, you know,
you just seem like you're somewhere else.
You just got to like the weight of the world. And he's sitting there going like,
I wonder if I'm eating somebody that helped me out one time.
Okay. Do, do, do, do [inaudible] that shit
[inaudible]
for some reason they would all come and help them.
They never really explained that. Did they? Why they all liked it.
Why they wouldn't interrupt whatever the fuck it is that they were doing to stop
some other fucking people in a boat.
Is it bringing a key of cocaine or some shit into the u s and it's just like,
like, oh, whale doesn't even know what cocaine is.
Why is it going to hurt its tail smashing this boat?
Because as much as it could smash the boat, this, this pointy stuff, right.
There's the mast and all of that. He can hurt himself
and all he gets is a thank you. Yeah. [inaudible] mango. Hey,
thanks a lot. By the way. There's a bunch of plankton over there.
Little heads up. No one's seen it yet. Ah, thank you aqua man. He never did.
You just be like, oh, thank you. Oh, fucking insecure.
These God damn fish.
Um,
here's another thing too. I'm sick of fucking hot. Newscasters,
male and female. All right. What do you, what are you trying to do here?
You know,
I don't need to be aroused when I'm fucking listening to world news.
Okay?
Holy Shit. What happened to that fucking ladies face? Well, it won't go down.
C'Mon. Go down. Scroll down. Oh Man. I, I don't,
I don't get how to use computers. There's something on the side. Where is it?
Where's The lady? All right. An Arizona woman played dead.
All right. Wait a second. Oh, this is all this clickbait stuff.
Kendall Jenner's nude photos, sparks. Who gives a shit?
She really is the best looking one of all of them, isn't she?
No offense to Kaitlyn. Um, all right, so I guess now we're going,
so we're going to, we're having a war with Afghanistan.
We're having one with Iraq and now we're going to have one with North Korea.
You know, isn't this like when Ho home depot opened so many fucking locations?
They like started putting each other on a business.
Um,
all right, Jesus Christ.
We're going to do another one. We're going to start another one out, right?
What are you gonna do? Hey, you know what the fuck I guess. I mean,
what do I know? I'm just another asshole.
But the podcast just trying to struggle through an hour.
Um,
you don't ever really wish I just wished like, you know,
why can't they just do it?
There's some guy shooting off his firecrackers. You don't like it?
Just go fucking do it. Stop dragging me into it.
Showing me what this guy could do and how his missiles can fucking, you know,
was a little Roman candle. Can fucking somehow land on my house.
So what does that do for me? Mike will do it.
They'll start putting some plywood up on top of my house.
I got hurricanes coming. It's Christ.
You're in the fucking navy. You Go, that's your job.
Does it world news when I can't put together my new hours, stand up.
Oh, shut up. Go Fuck Yourself. What do you want from me? Um, so, oh,
anyways, so my, my daughter was, uh,
grabbing onto this pleather couch that we have here. All right.
Cause she's learning, she's learning to crawl. And uh,
it was funny, she was like plank and today, you know,
doing like not like what the kids did on the Internet.
We just laid face down face planting is what I thought it should be called.
She was like literally doing, she was in upper push up position. How about that?
The upper push up position. Um,
and she was learning something and I know and I should've just let her figure
shit out instead and went, there you go, there you go.
And then she just dropped down to the floor and looked up at me and smiled.
I was like, yeah, just distracted. So anyways,
they got this pleather couch here and her fingernails are really long and a,
and she was making that thinking nail down the chalkboard sound and it was
driving me nuts. So against
my gut I decided to cut her fingernails, which I do.
Nia has told me to do. I said, I don't want to do it. Things are too small.
She wiggles him around it. It's, I don't want to do it.
So I got the first four done correctly and then I did her thumb and she made
this face and started crying and I looked,
cause she was wiggling her finger and I thought I was underneath it and I,
I just off just gave her the little, little,
little cut on it. I've got another families here. I got to go get some pizza.
I'll talk to you. I am, I really gonna pause in this right now.
So I made like a little cut on a finger and, uh, it was a,
I probably the worst feeling I've had as an adult.
And um,
you know, when she was fine two seconds later, but for the rest of the night,
every time she cried,
I was convinced it was because of that little fucking scratch I put on a finger.
Um,
worst fucking feeling ever. And I don't know why I had to pass it on to you,
but you know what,
if they could sit there and tell me that this little fucking fat shit over there
was shooting off his a, I guess that's what you do.
I'm going to let you know what's going,
everything awful that's going on in the world and I'll let you know what's going
on in my world. That was awful and a, all right. I gotta get off the, uh,
hang on a second. Hang on one second. Let me see what's going on.
As far as people who are coming over. Jesus,
I got too much family. He had to keep going.
I'll try to go for another few minutes here. So, uh, yeah, so that happened
and um,
just immediately stopped.
So now she has like short fingernails or one hand and long ones on the other.
And I'm trying to get my wife to clip the other ones she hasn't had the time and
it's driving me nuts aesthetically. You know what I mean?
It's like the fact that like
the fact that five of our fingers,
I have short nails and the other five don't is driving me fucking crazy.
I don't know why. It's the same thing.
You know when black guys walk around with their pants hanging off their ass,
like just that you just want to pull them up, you know?
And then the white guy version of that is that those white guys that walk around
with their shoes untied it fucking,
I don't know why it has no effect on my life. I don't know what it is.
It drives me up the wall. Pull up your pants,
tie your fucking sneakers. Okay. Can you be an adult?
Um,
you ever seen those guys that take it to the point?
Literally they have a long shirt on that goes past their ass and then they have
a belt. It's like,
I don't know how they can still walk. I saw a guy one time,
his pants were literally below his junk.
Um, I dunno.
He's crazy kids, you know, I guess they guys,
they have to keep taking it further than the generation before.
I figured at some point that someone's got to be a rebel and go the other way
and you start yanking them up, you know, till you do the old man thing,
which is right underneath your man boobs. Um, anyways, you don't want,
I became fascinated with since I got here because New York has changed so much
with all these glass towers. Um,
I get tallest building in Manhattan. This is new.
They used to be this place called the Drake hotel was Zeplin and all these guys
stayed. And uh,
this place that replaced it is four 32 park avenue
and you can have to see the fucking views of this place.
It's so, it's so tall.
Like you can see the roundness of the world or the flatness,
you know, depending on what you believe. You can see the end of like, you know,
those people that I think they think we kind of live in like a giant Coffee Cup.
Is that what it is? You know, I mean,
there has to be like, even people who fucking don't think it's round,
it's gotta be half round, right? Like you cut a tennis ball and half,
then you just filled it all in with land and ocean. Right?
Do they think it's like that? I don't know.
To this building on the top floor, they have this, this website.
I think on a clear day you can almost see the Tappan zee bridge.
You actually look over the freedom tower past the statue of Liberty,
pass that and island out to the ocean and the top floor.
I can't remember. I already talked about since bobcats went for $95 million,
I think he'd get the top two floors or something like that and then the floor
below it, the apartment below it, second highest one,
there's still for sale at 85 million bucks.
And I think in the reason why that isn't selling is who the fuck is going to pay
$85 million to still have some asshole walking on is salience.
Can Get fucking keep it down up there. You know,
some rich goat walking around. I think, you know, they probably the,
I would think at that point
you could literally be wearing tap shoes and like it's so expensive.
The person below, you can't hear it.
They got to have some sort of soundproofing or spongy floors.
I don't know what it is cause I know people who are that God damn bridge would
not tolerate listening to somebody walk.
You probably have a herd of horses up to the person below it wouldn't have it.
So probably the reason it's not selling is they just can't handle it.
They can't handle. If you have that kind of money,
you want to be the swinging Dick and you're building this somebody else above
you drop it as jumped on your forehead every time you walk out the window out
the door. Can't have that. Um,
what I did find interesting was that the,
the building was so tall that they actually had to call the FAA.
Um, cause I learned last time I was out here,
I flew um, up to a Gig in a helicopter, right?
I just want to see fly over the George Washington bridge just to do it. And uh,
he said Bravo airspace, which would be LaGuardia.
JFK in Newark was 900 feet and above.
And this building is like 1300 and change,
so it actually literally goes up into commercial airspace.
So at nighttime there's like these floors that are always lit,
which is pretty cool. And I don't know if that's because of the,
the FAA or what.
They usually just have like blinking red lights on the top or something like
that. Like, Hey, don't hit this man. Um,
anyways. I don't know who, who has, who has that kind of money?
Who is that kind of money? How long is that elevator ride?
And also how long before somebody based jumps off the top of that thing
and if you did, could you make it out to Ellis island? Actually,
you know something as far as like jumping, that's not that high up.
If you're going to try to fly right. When those guys don't,
they usually jump off. I bow on Ron Burger, burgundy,
I want to go shout it from Bob. Don't they don't say that.
You jump off a mountain. They go all the way down a mountain. Right. Jesus.
Bill, you've really talked yourself into a corner here, haven't you? Yeah,
I have. I have, you know what I was going to do last week,
I was going to sing the praises of a water taxi,
which I think I did a water taxi about how great it was,
underrated taking the water taxi in New York from,
from Manhattan to Brooklyn or vice versa there man and now to New Jersey,
whatever you want to do, it's awesome, right? And no sooner.
And I took the local to where we made like 10 stops and it took an extra half an
hour, but it was just relaxing and it was beautiful.
Um,
I made the mistake of saying how great it was in like three days after I said
that one of those yellow ones,
the guided slow down in time and he smashed into the dark and like 30 people got
hurt. Uh,
which means really probably 12 got hurt the other 18 and looking for a payday.
Yeah.
This guy just came cruising and he was probably texting.
I just don't understand how you screw up that bad
with the bowl.
There was the, the, the weather was fine. It was a clear day. Like,
what did you do? You just can't cruise it in that, that,
those probably the guys last run of the day that Chickie's been texted,
he wanted a banger. She finally texted them back, hey, what are you doing?
I'm at a bar on peer, whatever. Yay. And he was like,
oh well I'll get to go with DAB. Oh Shit, Bam. Wait,
buddy goes flying,
you know the boat I was on the guy driving it,
he's like surrounded by glass. So it's not like, you know, airline pilots,
you know, when they have a hard landing,
they just won't open the door and they just stay there. You know,
you can't see him cause then he'd go into the jetway. When you're on a boat,
there's nowhere to hide. You know, people just walked by. You just been last.
Sorry about the Jesus. Uh, sorry about that. Everybody laying on the ground.
Um, I know I'm not supposed to laugh at stuff like that,
but the end of the day I wasn't on the boat and no one I know got hurt.
So there is something kind of hilarious about it.
Unless somebody gets seriously injured, you know,
is this going to spark an internet controversy now?
Is they going to brew be a group of six people that complain all at the exact
same time and it gets picked up.
You know,
we're going to go to war with North Korea, but first podcasting,
can it go too far? Um, all right, 25.
I'm trying to get up to 30 minutes here cause I don't have any of the
advertising right now and I don't have any other questions either. Um,
the New York Yankees are crushing it. Ladies and gentlemen, they are a,
they were down five games to the a $200 million Boston red sox.
Uh, my $200 million Boston Red Sox, your $200 million ride songs. Okay.
Cause teams start spending that kind of money.
Like it's got to come from somewhere.
It can't just come from red sox fans and even comes from people who are not red
sox fans. So anyways, um, they,
I dunno, we lost so many fucking games in a row. We finally won last night,
Saturday night. I'm recording this Sunday and, uh,
one nine to eight actually scored a bunch of runs for once,
but the Yankees are just surgeon,
but they're only up by half a game and his leg, I don't know, 900 games left.
We'll see what happens. But, uh,
I'm watching the Yankees all week on the yes network here.
One of my favorite things to do, watch them and root against them.
It's what I always did. And when I get the baseball package,
I lived in New York for so long,
it's hard for me to turn on the red sox because I,
I for so long,
my baseball watching was watching the yes network rooting against the Yankees.
It's bizarre. Um, and somewhere in there,
sweet Caroline came out and I don't know,
this is just a bunch of weird shit that happens at Fenway now.
I went away for too long and I came back and I just don't recognize it. Uh,
but I am back into it and, um,
I really wish our team would just focus on trying to win and stop getting into
arguments with Dennis Eckersley. Alright. He's a hall of Famer.
He's, I love what he does. He's great in this job.
And I don't mind that he criticizes the fricking players and uh,
Jesus Christ. It's like all these stories that they, you know, people at the,
I get the fuck Outta here yelling at him on the,
on like the team plane and everything.
Like why would you do that to a hall of Famer, you know what I mean? If he,
if a hall of fame standup comedian criticized my act,
I would listen to it be like, all right, well shit,
evidently I need to work on some stuff. You know what I mean?
I certainly wouldn't start screaming at him on the team,
a comedian play, which is basically a commercial airliner.
Um,
alright I'm going to take a break now cause I got to go out with the family and
uh, I'll come back,
I read some advertising and some questions and we will wrap it up.
I have not watched the f one race yet cause I don't have the channel.
And like I mentioned earlier, um, you know,
I don't know a lot of people that are into it. None of my friends are,
so no one's really gonna ruin it for me. But if I had to guess, I really,
I hope Lewis Hamilton didn't win again.
I hope he's just not going to run away from this thing and it just becomes
Mercedes, Mercedes, Mercedes like it did last year. Uh, I help federal one,
you know, but just to keep it,
keep it exciting before they go on the break or whatever. Alright. That's it.
I'm done babbling. I will love, well for you guys. It'll be like two seconds.
I'll be back in two seconds. All right.
Hey and I'm back. I hope this isn't too loud.
I'm like fucking the battery ran out of my other thing. Um,
this is me continuing on with the Monday morning podcast. Oh, lovely.
Mia, how were you this morning? I know you're not in a good mood.
She's not in a good mood. You know,
every couple when you travel, there's the one person that's freaking out,
but they're going to miss the plane.
And then there's the other person who could like give a shit.
Knee is the one that freaks out. Like, Oh my God, did we leave enough time?
Did we bring extra batteries in case there's no flashlights on the plate?
Like I don't even know. I don't even know what airline, we're still,
oh delta. Are we in Delta?
I don't know. I never fucking know. You know when I on the way to the airport,
when the driver goes, you know,
I always know what airport I'm going to for the most part, the dude just goes,
what airline and it, that's when I check my itinerary, my itinerary.
I am going on virgin.
I am going on. You Knighted Umami baby. Um,
all right, so since I last talked to you, which was yesterday, uh,
the Yankees de Yankees lose but so did the red socks were still a half of gay
male by the way. New York sports press enough with the judge.
Shit. Jesus Christ all rise.
Then they had this thing, you know, cause he's got the gap between his teeth.
They like the tooth, the whole tooth and nothing but the till we get it.
His last name is judge Jesus. Fucking Christ. Why does,
why do sports pages get away with puns?
You know,
every fucking other day they got some stupid pun on the back of the sports page
cause they can't write a fucking joke and they shouldn't be able to,
cause the sports writers should just tell me who won the game. Okay.
I don't need you to say, Oh gee,
oh Coleen Jeter. Like why is it always have to be a pun
sitting in there? You're all a bunch of writers.
You can't come up with anything better than that. The tooth,
the whole tooth and nothing but the two,
well they just like fucking, it just ruined my goddamn day.
I hate when I record just off my fucking computer.
This fucking Goddamn air conditioning will not shut up.
Awesome. To shut off already.
So fucking loud off offs. Yeah.
Off. Why is it still on mode?
Low, high, fall low.
There's no fucking option here off.
That's it. Sorry.
It's fucking this fucking God damn air conditioning.
It either doesn't work or it's drowning out conversation. You know what I mean?
It's like somebody you just hope it's going to pass out.
But that last 10 minutes before they do that,
just interrupt and everybody sort this fucking air conditioning. It's like, um.
Anyways, let's get to some of the advertising here for this week. Uh,
where the fuck is it? Ah, that's not it. God Dang it. Come on. Come on.
We can do it. Ah, look. Oh look who's here. Oh, would you look at this?
It's so sip
Rick griller. Are you hiring well, are you,
um, do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates? Not the,
we'll settle for this person. Not the person who you know. Well,
at least he put deodorant under one arm pit. We want the best one,
the smartest, best looking, most fuckable candidate. Right? Who's kidding?
Who, that's what you want. You want people who know their job,
how to do it correctly and who look good. That's what you want. You know,
regardless of what these feminists might say,
regardless of what these fatties want to talk about, at the end of the day,
you want a good looking fuckable, reliable employee.
And that's where zip recruiter comes in. How is ZipRecruiter different? Well,
I'm glad you didn't ask. I'm glad the copy asked for you. With Zip.
Yeah.
You can post your job to 100 plus job sites with just one click.
Then their powerful technology or their basic caution on the Internet, oh,
we'll call it powerful technology,
efficiently matches the right people to your job better than anyone else.
And that's why zip. Sure.
My fucking tooth, my wedding ring is different. Unlike other job sites,
ZipRecruiter doesn't depend on candidates finding you goes out and grab them by
the balls and finds fines. In fact,
over 80% of jobs posted on ZipRecruiter get a qualified candidate in just 24
hours. No juggling emails or calls to your office.
Simply screen rate and manage candidates all in one place with zip.
Hey, easy to use dashboard.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has been used by businesses of all sizes to find
the most qualified job candidates with immediate results. There he is,
and right now my listeners can post jobs on ZipRecruiter for free. That's right.
Free. Just go to ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] that's
ziprecruiter.com/borrow one more time. Hi,
Zip.
[inaudible] dot com slash all alright. Oh,
movement watches MVMT watches pronounced movement was founded on the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank.
The watchmaker's goal is to change the way consumers think about fashion by
offering high quality minimalist products at revolutionary prices.
Movement watches start at just $95 at a department store.
You're looking at four to 500 bucks.
Movement figured out that by selling online,
they were able to cut out the middleman and retail mock up,
providing the best possible price. Classic design,
quality construction styled minimalism over 1 million watches sold in 160
countries.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to
movement.com/spur. This watch has has a really clean design.
Uh, seriously. I've been getting compliments ever since I put it on.
Um, no, no. Now is the time to step up your watch game.
Go to movement.com/for joined the movement. And lastly,
but not leastly the original advertisers of this podcast.
It's stamps.com stamps. Save the time and money,
which can you, you can use to grow your business. Shit.
I can mail any letter, any package, just using my computer printer in the mall.
Mailman comes and picks it up. I was reading so well.
Now I'm going to fuck up this last one.
Avoid the hassle man of the post office and mail everything from postcards to
envelopes to packages, domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes online with no equipment to lease.
No longterm commitments. Click print mail and you're done.
No need to lease an expensive postage. Maida.
I use stamps.com whenever I'm sending out my posters.
If I'm going to pour myself out after a show, if I can figure out how to use it.
So can you,
because I'm not smart and right now youtube can enjoy stamps.com service with a
special offer that includes a four week trial.
Four we trial with a jury of your peers plus postage and a digital scale without
longterm commitments. Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirththatstampsdotcomenterberberstamps.com
never go to the post office again. A, how bottom for OJ Simpson,
uh, pays out again. What's he gonna do?
He's out again. He's gonna kill that one,
but toe he's out again. It's Oh Jay,
run for your lives. I love when he said, you know, I've,
I've lived in a pretty confrontation confrontation free life.
And that is true other than when he killed those two people. I mean,
he was a hell of a guy. Um,
all right, here we go. Let's, um,
let's read some of the questions here for this week. Uh, microchipping says,
revelation 1317 is called mark of the beast.
That, sorry for this. Click here. This is going to be loud. Block your ears.
Three, two, one. Click. Um, what the fuck is it?
I know. I looked it up. There we go. Revelation.
This is the exact reason why I don't read the Bible. Uh,
library. Revelation three 17.
Let's see if I can get this here.
The temple of God was opened in heaven and there was seen in his temple,
the arc of his testament,
the arc of God's testament is the holy of holies.
The second apartment of the sanctuary.
I, I, you already lost me. Okay.
Evidently you can rent a room out in his church in the er or he has one of the
tenant, uh,
in the Minnis ministration of the early Tabernacle,
which served unto the example and shadow of heaven
of heavenly things.
This apartment was opened only by the Great Day of Atonement for the cleansing
of the sanctuary. Therefore, the announcement that the temple of God was opened.
Okay, well, there you go.
So I guess that explains microchipping thank you Bible.
That really is the good book. I mean, I, I would,
I think I,
I think I understand like computers more than I get the Bible. I just,
why can't they just write it in fucking today's English?
They do that with every other book of lies. No kidding. All right.
I work for the microchip company in Wisconsin. Okay.
Some stick fuck offered my boss a TV show.
A what the fuck are they going to call it?
How to shed your employees rights. Thanks asshole. Sorry. Just venting.
Love your stuff. Thank God for your gifts.
You don't punch a clock for Satan. Only the deal.
You just work for a company in Wisconsin quick the fucking job they want wanna
do. I Dunno. Collect unemployment and not be microchipped. Come on,
people don't give Delta Airlines your fingerprints.
All right. Please don't do this. People, please don't give in to this.
Don't go to Tiger Stadium and give them your fingerprints so you don't have to
stand in line for a fucking pretzel. You fucking dope.
And please don't be dumb enough to think we'll do my credit's fucked. Good luck.
If somebody steals my identity dummy,
they're going to create a false credit report.
All they need is the Lee Harvey Oswald dependent on which will be you and your
fingerprints. Your fucking dope. Yeah. You know,
in the future there's going to be a knock on the door and they're going to
question why you kill the fucking red you the Ukraine. And you'd be like,
I've never been there in my life. Oh yeah, your fingerprints were,
but it was sort of, here's this story of a person who didn't kill a hooker.
Now he's getting banked in the ass in the Ukraine
cause he left his finger prints at the ballpark cause he wanted a chorus light.
All right. Ah,
I'm sorry. All vacuums gathering information.
Uh Hey, big bald Billy thought you might enjoy this article in Rick Gads.
Do your reach the podcast on companies and fingerprints.
Now it seems like those robotic vacuums are selling maps of the inside of your
house so you can get furniture ads. Yay.
A massive Aussie Fan. Can't wait to hopefully see,
see you when I go over to the u s in the spring of 2018 yeah,
things are just changing. So frigging rapidly,
you know that was really going to be interesting is when they microchip
everybody. Okay,
they microchip everybody and then they put all the cash.
There's no longer any cash.
What's going to be interesting then is all these fucking, you know,
drug dealers, all these fucking,
I don't know anybody who just didn't trust banks and put a sack of money in the
fucking wall. What do you do with that now?
You know,
now it's all on you. Now that's not even worth anything.
You got to show up with all this shit. They be like, hey man,
where did you get this money? And you're gonna be like, Hey man,
I earned this money and I already paid taxes on it, man. They going to be like,
hey man, you got to prove that and like, hey man, I can't,
and then I'm going to be like, hey man, fuck your bag of cash.
What's going on? Nino? Do you like my song a bucket microchips do, do, do,
do to is this story? Ah, you just walking on, you're getting ready and yeah,
you get so nervous on days what we fly.
Jesus. Okay, well that was fun. Yeah. So anyways,
these fucking lazy ass fat fucks by these computers that just,
these little robots, that fat that sweep up after him, you know,
as they're eating like Ritz crackers with like ice cream in the middle of it.
Whatever fat people do, right? They're always creating some new food,
some unholy matrimony of Crock.
Cabo hydrates in fucking sugars.
Um,
they're too fucking lazy to get off their ass and use a vacuum cleaner.
So they have this robot to it and then they map the inside of this person's
house, you know, so they can do what with it? I don't fucking know.
So they can sell them an l shaped couch. In fact,
people sit on l shaped couches. Can they swing their leg up to that? You know,
that other side of us,
I don't know why I'm making fun of the fatties today because I started with that
fucking guy over there in, uh,
whatever his fucking name. I don't even know the guy's name because the lead,
you know, cause he's crazy. I don't need to know about this guy. Um,
we should get him to come over to the fucking Detroit Tigers ballpark in his
fingerprints and we'll put it on something and we'll go over there and we're a
restaurant. We'll stick them in. Ojs outsell.
Um,
how mad would he be? Can you imagine if that guy ever went to jail?
Just standing there,
you know,
all that hair on top of his head, but nowhere else on his body. You know,
he's one of those weird hairless adults. Right? All right.
Girlfriend broke up with me because I like your podcast. Uh,
thanks me. Thanks for helping me weed out the cops, mate.
Come back to s k sometime. Saskatchewan.
Hope you enjoyed it. There girlfriend broke up with me because I like your puck.
I would like to heard more details on that one.
What was it that she didn't like about the podcast? My annoying voice.
My tone deaf singing, my inability to read out loud.
Um, all right. Addiction to online prostitution to ocean to ocean.
Dear Trojan Bill. Over the course of the last year,
I've become addicted to online prostitution, juice exchanges. Christ too.
The courage you have, you just go online.
[inaudible] she was just have her come over to your fucking place like you're
ordering it. God Damn Pizza.
What does it like when you look through that fucking hole and you see her
walking down the fucking hallway, the hole in your door,
whatever you call that thing, the little psych thing,
she comes stumbling out of the elevator. Um,
it started off as curiosity.
What would it be like to fuck a stranger for money and snowballed into me
spending a percentage of almost every paycheck on hookers,
anywhere from 60 to hundred 300 try to stick with the $300 plucker.
You really get what you paid for. Photo book is this story
of a bunch of venereal diseases. He said,
I broke up with my girlfriend a few months ago. She had no idea,
but I didn't want to drag her into this. Well, Joe, you can't fucking do this.
When you were in a relationship with somebody,
you said,
I recently got tested and I came up clean thank God was what I was going to say
and he wrote it too. Thank God.
No one knows what that I do this and I prefer to keep it that way,
but I can't help myself from going onto those websites and meeting with these up
with these women. I feel like it's getting worse every month.
It's already cost me my relationship.
It's costing me a fortune and I'm too embarrassed to ask anyone I know for help.
What should I do?
And I'm sorry if Nia is in the room and completely disgusted by this.
I'm pretty disgusted with myself too. All right.
This is what you have to do. The second you wake up, you gotta rub one out.
All right? And then you go to work and at lunch you go, that was delicious.
Excuse me. And you excuse yourself.
You go in and you rub one out at them in the bathroom right now, unless you can,
unless you can't lock the door. And then when you come home, rub one out again.
Okay. And then that's it.
And then you take your fucking phone and you throw it in the freezer.
If you have a landline, you rip it out of the wall. Um, I actually, I,
if I was you, if like this is like, did you spend in this amount of money?
I would just, uh, I would go to a therapist,
get up and just say, yeah, I'm addicted to online prostitution.
I mean therapist to hear everything. Okay.
That's actually like,
that's like easy listening music to them compared to some of the shit they'd
have to, you know,
people come in there and talk about how they got molested by one of their
parents. I mean, it's crazy shit. You're just like, hey, you know what,
like banging and hookers. It's cost me a lot of money and I'd like to stop.
And they'd be like, oh my God, you're sort of functional. By all means.
Lay down on my couch and let's fucking talk about this.
Why do you feel you want to get prostitutes?
Why wouldn't you want to be with a real girl? A regular woman?
Um, all right. I snooped through my husband's phone. Isn't that a song,
isn't it? I snooped through my husband's phone and I liked it, isn't it?
That's fucking Serrano. Good morning Billy. Good morning, Billy. Uh,
on Sunday morning,
my husband had his work phone alarm set to 5:30 AM of course,
the only person it wakes up is me. After I turn the alarm off,
I decided to go through his phone. You fucking pores.
Do we go through your shit itself? The SEC fucking horse.
I have to admit that it wasn't my proudest moment. All right then I forgive you.
You're a nice person. I'm see. I just jump around,
but I am insecure while looking at his message,
I see that there are texts from a phone number without contact information and
quickly figure out it is his ex-girlfriend's number and the text message.
There's a lot of flirting as well as my husband complaining about my appearance.
Oh, Jesus Christ. Well,
this is what you get for snooping and eventually asking her to get drinks
together while we were visiting his family for father's day in their home town.
Oh Jesus.
They were together for six years on and off through college and high school.
She cheated on him more than once.
Um, then when we got together,
she harassed me on Facebook and took an eight hour bus ride to try and meet me.
Oh yeah. So this bitch is crazy and she's great and bet that's what's going on.
I had to ignore all my initial reactions toward her and just ended up ignoring
her. I didn't want her in my life.
I confronted him about it and his only response was why would I go into his
phone and that if I go looking for something, I'm going to find it.
Jesus Christ. When I asked him why he did it, he just said he didn't know.
He has ignored me ever since.
I'm not sure where to go from here. Thank you. Uh,
you are amazing at colossal cluster fest.
Too bad you didn't get to finish your set. Hopefully you're in the bay area.
It gets to all right. You know something.
I apologize for call neural Hor 15 fucking times in all of womanhood. Divorce.
Um, well he's not leaving any doors open here.
I guess what I do is
Nia. Oh, she's too busy packing.
I Dunno. What do you do here? You're married. You, you have kids.
Unless you would just visiting his father for father's Day.
Um,
well he's being a total bitch about it. I can tell you that.
I think you kind of needed to have the what the fuck conversation like, uh,
do you think if you just like, ignore me, this is going to go away.
Well, hey, you know, what'd you snoop to my phone for?
If you're looking for something used to find, well yeah, well I did and I did.
Would you say that to the cops? Yeah,
we find a kilo of cocaine in the trunk of your car. Well,
what the fuck he going through the trunk of my car for be fucking looking for
something. You got to find it. The cops gonna be like, Oh, okay.
MMM. [inaudible]
he fucking deserves to give you a fucking explanation.
A little better than that. And then you decide if you want to work through it.
And if he doesn't want to work through it, fucking dump his ass. This, this is,
this is the best you can do. I mean, come on,
you're better than this. Anybody's better than this.
Fuck this guy. All right,
fuck. Is this good guy? Get off pulling a move like that. No.
Our response like that.
Wow.
You know, I, I don't, I don't get that and that's 100% not fair to you.
Fuck this guy. Okay. And I'm not saying the leave the guy,
but if he's not going to discuss it with you,
then the fucking relationships over right. The trust is gone.
Um, all right, good luck with that. And I'm sorry you're going through that.
That's, that's really a,
the unbelievably painful and that's one of the worst fucking responses ever
slash a little legendary. I'm not gonna lie to you.
I'm teaching guitar to a cute girl and on Jaycees please tell me she's of age.
I don't like the sound of this already. All right. Hi Bill.
I've been listening to your podcast for a while now.
Just picture this old guy applying Ben Gaze. He listens to this. Um,
and now no, and I now know you lend,
you tend to give some solid romantic relationship advice.
So I was wondering if you, and maybe the lovely Nia too, if she's around,
could help me out with this one. About two years back,
I met this girl in my let, in my last year of university.
We had a lot of the same classes together. So we started talking.
We have a lot of the same interests. She's really smart.
She's funny and Nice and just all around my type,
but it turns out she had a boyfriend so I backed off pretty quickly.
To this day we're friends and we try to meet up every couple of weeks.
Is this when Harry met Sally or is this actually your, um,
so about two months ago she messaged me saying she always wanted to learn how to
play guitar and that she finally bought one disc she wants, she's in the,
you do. I've been playing guitar for years,
so I told I'd be happy to meet up with her and show her some easy stuff to get
her started.
It slowly morphed into this thing where every week we meet up after work for a
couple hours. I teach,
I'll teacher cords and stuff and we'll talk about life in general. Anyway.
I noticed lately that a good chunk of the conversations
and about how she's been fighting with her boyfriend,
the same guy as when we first met.
Yet how many more fucking signals to your need, Jesus' crisis.
You not put Christmas lights around her fucking vagina there.
She's also keeps telling me how amazing on being for teaching her guitar.
And now I'm such a great guy.
Plus the last few week if ever a boyfriend calls them were together,
she's been sending it straight to voicemail. Okay. Alright. Alright.
Well what does she have to do?
Grab you by the back of your neck and fucking push your face towards her?
I mean, come on, I'm starting this, this guy goes,
I'm starting to get the feeling she might be interesting,
call me crazy, but this is where I need your advice.
I tend to overthink things. Uh, yeah.
I would say because I tend to overthink things a lot in general and I've
actually had issues with anxiety slash depression in the past.
I was wondering if you and Nia could help me out here and I'm reading,
am I reading too much into things or does it seem like she's actually showing
some interests? I'll take any help on what I should do here.
Congrats on your lovely daughter and getting the show picked up for season
three. Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Um, yes sir. Jesus Christ.
You're low self esteem jackass. Yeah, she's in to you.
So what do you mean what you should do here? Just our team.
Tell her how you feel. I would just say, listen,
I hope I'm not out of line here. I know you have a boyfriend.
I would, I would just ask her. I said, so what's going on with your boyfriend?
You don't seem happy. You know,
you're always sending it to Tennessee and you're always fighting your sending it
to the voicemail. You know, you don't seem happy, happy.
And this is a 40% chance there's that. She might cry
when she finally says No.
Um,
and just say, listen, I really like you and I don't,
I don't like seeing you unhappy. All right. And not for nothing.
Do you ever broke up with that guy?
I'd love to take you out some time now.
Would you like to learn how to do what at half court? That's it.
How about that? F as in fuck me. Um, yeah, that's what I would do.
I just asked her about her relationship and she's going to say it's not going
well, and then just say, well, you know,
just say what the fuck I just said it. Put it in your own words. All right.
What am I seeing her no diversion rack over here?
Is that the right guy that the guy tell her you're the man.
Remember that? What was that? Uh, that was at Rodney Dangerfield movie.
All right. I gotta go to the fucking airport. It's nine o'clock.
We'll get picked up in 45 minutes and I haven't even packed yet or had my
fucking breakfast sandwich there.
Um,
oh, that's it. That's it. Yeah. That is it. Go Fuck Yourself.
I will check in on you on Thursday and I'm going to go home today.
I'm going to watch the Formula One race. That's what the fuck company. No,
I'm not. I'm landing and I'm going directly
and do the, uh,
F is for family shit. I got to go back and start writing again. Okay. That's it.
Go fuck yourselves. I'll check in on you.
Oh, I know.
I already said this on Thursday. All right. Bye.